all right julio jones will be playing
for another team this year most likely
he told
shannon sharp yesterday on
undisputed i'm out of there not quite
sure that he knew he was on there live
on the air when he said it
uh but uh you know we should we call
this the julio jones memorial draft
should we take him off the board i mean
receivers who will make the hall of fame
i i i'm okay with that if you want to i
mean first off let's let's talk about
that i know i made that statement before
as far as he's a first ballot hall of
famer uh listen you you tell me mike i i
view julio jones
as
as really one of the five greatest
receivers in the history of football i
think i do i was kind of thinking about
this the last like 48 hours i think he's
right off the cusp of terrell owens and
randy moss and of course jerry rice
those one two three right there i i
certainly think you could make the
argument julio's four or five whatever
you want to say if you agree with that
or what do you think
i feel like numbers drive a lot of this
he's 20th all time in receiving yards
he's still got more gas in the tank and
as we mentioned yesterday when we were
drafting most impressive old man feats
in the nfl jerry rice was 33 when he
generated over 1800 receiving yards
which was the record from 1995 until
calvin johnson broke it in 2012. so
we've got to see what more he has to do
he's on track he's on track right but i
still think he's got it he's got to
continue
to
pile up the numbers
and play at a high level and it wouldn't
hurt to get a super bowl ring yeah all
right you got it so let's let's
we're gonna let's leave him in the mix
let's leave him in the mix okay let's do
that let's not make it the julio jones
memorial draft you got a trivia question
for me yeah i got a question for you and
um do you want to erase the question on
there matt casey or do you want me to
i'm not looking at it i know he didn't
even erase it i can't see it i can't
even see it so here we go there we go i
don't know he says he texted me in 1964
alabama phillip has your phone joe
namath threw four touchdown passes all
season
as the tide claimed a controversial
national title
despite losing their final game in the
orange bowl to what team
joe namath they lose the orange ball
win the national championship what team
beat them
notre dame
nope nope sorry
texas fight
texas fight
hook of horns baby how come freaking
horns that's right jason what what do
you get what do you ask me baseball
trivia next i thought the trivia was
supposed to be football nfl related
i don't come up with this what are you
what are you talking what are you
talking to me for you i barely
researched these drafts you think i'm
looking up for these questions now too
okay go ahead well i'm going to take the
first one i'm taking julio jones yeah
yeah julio jones you know again i i
think he's one of the greatest to ever
play i really do there's no there's
nothing about his game that's not
awesome good route runner size
50 50 balls catch a slant run 60 yards
throw a bomb 60 yards touchdown i mean
he can do everything he's one of the
greatest specimens to ever play the
position you know every year he is a guy
that whoa you're playing the falcons we
got to double him we got to have a plan
for julio all those type of things uh
yes i will take julio jones as my first
pick
i will go with a guy who still has
plenty more work to do but he's done
plenty of work in his seven nfl seasons
and he has something julio jones doesn't
which is a super bowl ring although i
don't think they've gotten them yet mike
evans first guy to have seven straight
thousand yard seasons to begin his
career that was a record setter he's
quiet he's understated he's overlooked
at least was overlooked until last year
when tom brady came to town right but i
think
when when it's all said and done for him
it will be a no-brainer he's still got
more work to do
but i believe he will get there he's
already
had as good of a start as anyone
just from a standpoint of consistency
great performance being that guy that
you want to double cover and he still
gets his numbers mike evans my pick yeah
i like that mike i mean i i i didn't you
know i don't think he gets put into that
category quite enough really
uh but there's there's a lot of special
about his game and you're right i feel
like it almost hurts him that he's you
know he's an under the radar guy he's
not your typical
loud you know flamboyant type receiver
so that's where it's a little different
that way but yeah damn is he a good
football player no doubt about that good
pick by you really um
oh
all right well i'm gonna go antonio
brown antonio brown's next my next pick
i mean he's the wide receiver of the the
tens or the teens or whatever the hell
decade we just came from what the hell
you call the the the tens i don't even
know but either way he was the wide
receiver of the decade i don't know yeah
i i agree no you're right okay
i mean either way yeah he was that guy
uh fantasy all you know leader every
week but come on antonio brown
pittsburgh steelers you know just like
we talked about with
a little bit like julio jones maybe not
the size but the route running special
the ability to make people miss in space
you know can beat you deep can catch it
short still do those things so antonio
brown's as good a receiver as as i've
seen that's for sure
here's the question though yeah does he
get i know
dinged for
the issues he created post-pittsburgh
yeah because
they're very very clear
that off-field issues are not a factor
they're not really off-field issues when
they
directly affect on-field performance
whether it's the frozen feet from two
years ago the stupid helmet thing
getting cut by the raiders just creating
distractions and issues and it was the
overlap you know when when the off-field
stuff keeps you from playing when you
miss all of 2019 except for one game
because you have this thing looming that
the nfl may put you on paid leave for
and you're not able to play that affects
your performance it affects your
production and yeah i i don't know that
it's one of the reasons why they make
everyone wait five years for the good
and the bad to subside so people can get
a full look at the guy but you know i we
said
i think before the super bowl we did a
draft of the guys whose hall of fame
cases would most be boosted by a win and
i think antonio brown was one of my
picks so i i just it there's a there's a
lot that remains unwritten with him as
it relates to how the voters react to to
where his career went after
2018. i'm going to go tyreek hill tyree
kill wow
if he's the greatest deep threat of all
time so they say they tell me he's the
greatest deep threat of all time randy
moz may object to that but he's on track
to become a hall of famer the way he's
played his first five nfl seasons uh i'm
i've only been in for five years i know
i'm mad i did i was hoping you'd forget
him i thought you're gonna take somebody
else really but yeah i agree with you i
don't care it doesn't matter i mean it's
it's on hall of fame trajectory
and it's not going to be maybe all about
catches and yards it's going to be about
the pressure it's going to be about the
touchdowns that's his worth what's this
the the statistic that the guy gets the
ball in his hands and scores 18
touchdowns every year what does that
mean to your team that's where he's
amazing now i'm stuck i i really didn't
think you were going to take him there
and i was
too bad i'm now i'm on like larry fitz's
hasn't officially retired
like do i want to take larry fitz is
that legal i mean i think we think he's
retiring but do you do does that count
matt casey commissioner of this draft
because i couldn't go dk i could go aj
green i could go deandre hopkins
but i mean i'll go with larry fitz he
hasn't retired yet is that okay am i
good with that yeah i was gonna do it if
you didn't so yeah it's hard for me to
say that you can't okay good
that makes me feel better i'm definitely
taking them then screw your pick all
right good yes i'm taking larry fitz
great catch you know i mean he's awesome
so there you go go ahead who's yours
does julian edelman count
um i'll i'll take deandre hopkins since
you're going to leave him on the board
yeah i think he'll end up there by the
time it's all said and done he's still
got plenty of chapters left in his book
but he's had a great career all